welcome to this video playing bustle tap
gay when I tap G ok this is a funky
account yeah here's a crap blitz rating
of 1800 but 2305 minute and it's from
Egypt right no this is Syria I'm sorry
it's difficult to see but this is the
same color so I cannot really see those
stars or whatever dists tutus too little
at least I didn't confuse the for the
lack of France with the Netherlands as
some other youtuber recently did but
I've made my share fair share of
mistakes in that that regard as well
okay so let's see what we get classical
names oh yeah d5 that's not very common
but not bad transpose this into some
sort of rogozin variation of the Queens
gambit knight c6 it's strange move white
normally provokes this kind of thing
with Queen a form you often want to have
the night on d 7 & M get get c5 in but
is not going for that at all
okay g5 that's it's a very ambitious way
to play can know that this is a it's a
very double-edged way to play in many
cases your kind of over extending a
little bit but in many others you're
you're gaining space on the Kings Island
some concrete play so it's it's not
necessarily bad just as I set ambitious
okay I don't know pawn takes f pawn
takes is also not not not bad probably
to open up their file but I want to play
it in this in a more simple way in a
more simple way in a simpler way let's
try proper English here for once okay
wow that was quickly played yeah takes
takes 92 is definitely slightly better
for me okay let's do that queen bee
three was also good f5 g4 is the point
yeah here white is better do to them in
due to the better central control he has
the MOOC g3 however even move the night
now to some unlucky spot so let's do
this it's not the best possible square
for the night but want to prevent age
five and block vporn advanced
interesting the King g6 interesting way
to play
ok let's try to provoke a weakness there
with b6 so a serious weakness but still
it's not threatening to take them but
still my ideas rugby five ok so I'm
going here threatening look be five like
b6 text a crook c7 night is not well
placed on a five
ok so c6 is going to move the beep on
interesting rook is Roxy 3 and move here
mmm look C 3 a 3 maybe
hmm i'd like to get the night back into
the game where exactly me to each watery
for I don't know
hmm
that's actually also interesting d5 Andy
449 f5 possibly okay the e4 pawn can be
a problem but it's interesting that's an
interesting setup quite active i also
have f3e to further support your phone
and marching those pawns cannot cannot
be bad really but strange of it is bad
interesting not sure what is best
offense is lamb it's not not easy to
play
yeah that was possible I said let's say
a move that I had on the agenda at least
thinking f3 is not bad I can take and
play g4 again maybe this one for 92 94
and I have group a 4 as a possible move
that's attacking f2
I didn't consider that move at all
mm-hmm interesting
95mm may be tough to play him rook takes
at five s always a check time warning f3
wow what a difficult position oh we can
just take it twice I totally overlooked
that one ok but I can try to get to go
4936 check do this there's not check
that's not a check that's just stupid I
wanted to go 96 check but it's not a
check it's not difficult to see ah ok
maybe the D pawn can help me him so move
him don't believe it believable stuff
now this was such a great position
really
such a shame em blundering this away
Jeff Jeff Jeff
yeah and g2 white resins frustrating
somebody frustrating I mean this
disposition is just just brilliant for
white ham just so nice big centers got
this totally crappy night on a five and
i'm still bungling this away Joe rook
rook those move that feel wrong are
wrong it's so happen look see to it just
look kind of wrong to protect us this is
after this it just resins the bloody
game I'm just winning this piece why
didn't that do this I really don't know
I really don't know sometimes it's just
just over he just loses the piece you
can do this i take here and enjoy this
check and everything it's just bloody
stupid yeah i don't know i mean i still
better after Luke c2 of course but after
the other stuff was just winning it just
winds and now I played f3 which is
totally ridiculous i told i just
overlooked that with the rook back on c
2 f 3 is just not protected yeah i can
still play rookie to end i'm quite
clearly better i think yes simply
because you put this night on this
ridiculous a five square which is just
okay anyway it doesn't help if i lose at
the end yeah yeah I'm still much better
after have three of course I'm not check
check this and now I was really thinking
I can play like route 96 check which
stays no check and this is just just
hauling yeah nothing I can do this is
just lost yeah I really really gave away
this game on a silver plate he should
never ever win it never
this is just fantastic I mean I don't
really know how you can come up with
this kind of plan putting the night on
the edge of the board and I know but it
doesn't matter if you if you play it
like I did you can do everything ok
thanks for watching